[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
what's fun about this show is that you
never know if tonight is the night where
one of these people snaps right now like
I'm three feet away from someone who's
so unwell
so mentally deranged that you have no
idea if tonight's the night did they
just decide to do something Wild
and uh so that's the fun of this last
week Bert Chrysler posted a poll on his
Instagram story asking fans to vote on
who the greatest two Bears won cave
guest of all time is well that got me
thinking who the greatest guest for
other comedy podcasts would be so we
decided to put this poll in our
community section and asked 137 000
comedy fans who is the greatest kill
Tony guest of all time to start off with
the four options were theoven Shane
Gillis Mark Norman Joe Rogan and other
in comment over 17 000 people voted on
the poll and things were pretty even for
a while there but eventually theovan was
able to pull away with 43 percent of the
votes I used to lift weights with David
Duke dude what
I did
I swear to God we shared a bad events
when I was growing up
really yeah we used to go do we used to
go to chest a lot you talk about that in
your stand-up uh-uh you are the funniest
person I've ever met
isn't that when I say you think I have a
bad hoodie
you really lifted weights with David
he's a nice guy I mean overall I mean I
didn't get into any of his practices did
your muscles burn like a cross
afterwards
[Music]
what do you mean oh how do you feel
funny that's your reality and you have
not spoke about that on stage are you
kidding me that's crazy damn you have
some stuff to dig into seem like a d i
mean he I mean I'm not gonna everybody's
gonna judge him but I mean at the time
he was you know non-practicing
non-practicing and uh stop stop lips
yeah and he just seemed pretty casual
and liked hit the gym I like to hit the
gym he was dating this pretty girl that
worked at the seafood restaurant this
video is sponsored by raid Shadow
Legends raise the first game to bring a
true Council level experience to your
phone they've set the bar high and
there's no going back explore millions
of champion combinations and master
countless tactics as you take on raid
bosses dungeon runs campaign battle and
PVP Arena matches with literally
hundreds of artifacts to equip in over
600 Champions each blessed with unique
skills you can build your team develop
your Champions and raid your way I've
been playing raid now for a while and
these are some of the personal Champions
that I like to use the royal guard is
sick he has an extremely powerful
ability that scales damage based on
enemy Max HP that's in addition to all
the other damage it deals I also like
Venus she's a very versatile Champion
that can perform well in each aspect of
the game with the first skill Venus
attacks on one enemy two times and has a
chance to place a poison debuff and
right now raid's running an amazing
trick-or-treat Halloween promotion where
you can can win in-game and real-life
prizes including a thousand dollars in
Amazon gift cards and some of the best
epic and legendary Halloween champions
in raid all you need is your raid player
ID just download raid with my link in
the description then head over to trick
or treat.polarium.com that's it but
don't wait around because this special
opportunity only lasts from October 15th
to November 5th and once it's done it's
done click the link in the description
right now or scan this QR code on screen
from there just enter your information
spin the wheel and collect your prize
this offer is only for new players
you'll get bonuses worth thirty dollars
including energy refill XP boost silver
ancient Shard and more and you can claim
your reward here for the first 30 days
Duncan and I are so high right now I
want some of that weed we're almost
imperceivably high pull the weed out we
just did a three and a half hour podcast
and just got in a car and came over here
and the whole way over we're talking
about woolly mammoths and Hollow Earth
hollow Earth yeah yeah but what's the
dumbest conversation I've ever had in my
life hey you know in Waco every second
of it Waco's the biggest woolly mammoth
Museum in the world up there it's a
giant woolly mammoth dig
me up you it's a good point though
even with 43 of the votes most of the
comments and support for Theo were at
the same time split between him and
Shane Gillis this guy said theovan is
great when he gets past insecurity and
talks more up there Shane is just
unmatched once he gets rolling on the
buds and the sighties Taylor Cox said
very hard to choose between Shane and
Theo and Danny said Shane's hands down
Theo wasn't that great on kill Tony in
my opinion now if this was just a vote
for funniest podcast guests in General
on any podcast not just kill Tony
there's no doubt in my mind Theo would
win this by a landslide but because this
is kill Tony it is a little bit
different and after re-watching all of
Theo's episodes I can see where people
are coming from when they say he might
not be the greatest kill Tony guest of
all time and honestly I think that's
because he doesn't really like hurting
The Comedians feelings in the interview
portion and unfortunately or fortunately
if you like the show that's a huge
aspect of the show I feel like Theo
wants to be polite to them even when he
does roast them he quickly apologizes
after it says he's just kidding do you
see you just cheat on your girlfriend
with multiple no I I've actually never
cheated this is uh yeah it's your wacky
character your lovable character
everybody yeah
I'm too lovable in real life you never
cheated or you just realized that you
were on a live podcast
well I don't have a girlfriend and I've
never cheated honesty you don't even
have a girlfriend no I'm not you're a
dirty I don't have a girlfriend what
does Garfield do nobody
never
no no no no no no no you don't even have
a girlfriend are you really even a bad
to me
and we're off do you even joke bro you
used to be one too come on sorry I was
kind of rude no no I like Joe that was
great
for me so it takes a lot of Bravery to
be up there man I felt nervous right
when you're standing there and he's he's
[ __ ] anarchists behind you I would
feel uncomfortable
but uh nice Anarchist but still um by
far the most comments on this poll were
for Shane Gillis specifically drunk
shingles this guy said the young bull
getting absolutely shredded and slurring
was epic what a unit
Shane's middle school bully humor is
perfect for kill Tony's environment see
that might be the thing that Theo's
missing a little bit of the middle
school bully mindset
shame tickling and Tony and acting
flamboyantly with each other is the
funniest [ __ ] I've ever seen when Tony
stood on the chair and Shane fingers ass
was gold stop
[Applause]
stop touching him once
this goddamn fruitcake
[Applause]
[Music]
I had a couple drinks I need a little
hands yeah I touched some guys
I've touched some guys sometimes it's a
fun joke
I I love it the other two comedians on
the poll Joe Rogan and Mark Norman
basically tied with Joe Rogan raking in
11 of the poll and Mark Norman receiving
nine percent of the votes Mark Norman
and Shane but probably Mark if I had to
choose one found City fingerboard said
shingles arshafir Mark Norman and drunk
Joe Rogan so basically the whole protect
our Parks crew after a podcast of
drinking on JRE Matt K said Camp aside
between Shane Mark and atel and Chad
Regal said you have to put two different
Joe Rogan's Joe drunk and Joe sober
because sober Joe calm and chill while
drunk show roasts everyone and is hella
loud which is couldn't be more true you
misunderested me like tomorrow who's
been misunderestimated Lee on Edwards
[ __ ] I did not believe this in
the last minute let's [ __ ] go I would
have thought we'd see Norm Macdonald
before Joe Rogan tonight this is crazy
let's do a [ __ ] puzzle okay let's
play poker [ __ ]
comedians in that other in comment
category that receive the most comments
were Tim Dillon Dave Attell Ron White
and Alex Jones as a guest obviously not
a comedian I also should mention that
the regulars on kill Tony like Hans Kim
David Lucas Willie Montgomery those guys
were not included as guests for this
poll but they did receive a lot of love
in the comments nonetheless Dane said
Alex Jones by Miles and Miles Alex Jones
the first time he was on and drinking
Casey said I think the recent episode
with David tell is my favorite so far I
think a big part of that was from the
guest though I'm gonna vote Ron White
gives great advice and words of
encouragement also hilarious and James
King said Tim Dylan is great at kill
Tony almost like a second host are you
living here now yes like yeah yeah it's
Austin's like the big city right oh he's
massive yeah what part of it what part
four blocks
three of them are closed for a homeless
wedding or whatever the hell this
downtown is a dump
tell Joe Rogan to get us the [ __ ] out of
here anyway I'm kidding I'm kidding yeah
great to be here great to be here they
all lied to us him and Ron white lie to
us they said come to come to Austin get
out of L.A get away from all the traffic
and homeless people right you know what
I uh
I really think that you got to cut some
of this edge off that because it just
doesn't come off as real you don't seem
like that mean a guy so either learn how
to act meaner when you get up here uh
come off as holiest and then sell this
darker stuff or do but it just doesn't
sound like you're being true to your
nature to me you know I don't know if
that's true or not but it seems like
you're not that person and you're trying
to be that person on stage and I don't
you know have I think it'd be more
interesting if you're just who you are
oh thank you honest advice so it seems
like no matter who you prefer as a kill
Tony guest everyone's a little bit
better when they're drunk or in Rogan's
case literally blacked out feel free to
comment who your favorite kill Tony
guest of all time is on this video and
thank you so much for watching if you're
looking for a page to keep up with the
entire comedy scene all at once please
consider subscribing to joke world right
now and if you want even more comedy
content in your life we also have an
Instagram where we're posting similar
stuff we'll also send you free joke
World stickers in the mail if you shoot
us a DM thank you again for watching and
I'll see you Monday with the comedy news
foreign
[Music]